字幕: Mai Iida
校正: Ayako Ezaki
こんにちは
私は松島でカステラ屋をしている
千葉と申します
正直 TEDすごく恥ずかしくて
出たくなかったんですけども
やはり ５代続く商家の後継ぎとして生まれ育ち
そしてバブルの崩壊や 東日本大震災
そういったピンチを乗り越えた末に見えてきた
経営の考え方
そういったものを伝えたくて
今日ここに立っています
経営論ではありますが
一種の幸福論でもありますので
経営者じゃない方にも聞いて頂けたら嬉しいです
私は1975年生まれ
いわゆる団塊ジュニアの世代と呼ばれる世代です
青春時代はバブルの雰囲気にあまり馴染めずに
パンクミュージックを聴きながら
サリンジャーとかを読んでいるような
そんな少し冷めた青春時代を送っていました
しかしその頃 バブルが弾けて
うちの経営が危うくなって
急にカーネギーを読み始めるんですね
だからそんなサリンジャーとかカーネギーとかが
ミックスされた
ちょっぴりパンクでポップな経営論です
これは創業当時のチラシの画像です
明治44年とあります
西暦に直すと1911年
しかしうちはカステラ一筋100年という商売では
なかったんです
時代に合わせながら 同時に時代に翻弄されながら
なんとか続けてきたと言えるでしょう
この100年を簡単に振り返ってみたいと思います
創業当時の写真が残っていました
赤い矢印のところがうちです
そして昭和初期 看板には
「カフェー松島 洋食」とあります
そして昭和50年 この年は僕が生まれた年です
周りはコンクリートのビルになってきていて
高度成長を感じます
両親は忙しくて
あまり遊んでもらった覚えがないんですけども
目の前の海で釣りをしたりですとか
裏山で冒険ごっこをしたりですとか
楽しかった覚えもあります
平成に入るとバブル景気になっていきます
この頃はそれぞれの店やホテルが
どんどん大きくなってきて
町並みも変わっていきました
物質的には 一番恵まれていた時代だったと思います
ただやはり今思い起こすと お金に踊らされていた感は
否めないのではないかなと思います
そしてバブルが弾けると
うちが経営のピンチに陥って
一時は倒産寸前までいきます
その頃 私は大学を卒業したので
就職をせずに そのまま家を手伝いました
とても辛い日々だったんですけれども
家族と喧嘩もしながら一致団結して
なんとか少しずつ回復していきました
倒産は回避できたので
一度社会勉強をしたいと思って
私はその後 霞が関でネクタイを締める経験をします
この経験が私にとってすごく大きかったように思えます
というのはやはり 外に出たことによって
東北の素晴らしさや 松島の素晴らしさを
認識することができました
そして 2003年の ［宮城］北部地震の時に
うちが大変だということで
また戻ってきます
そんなことがあって 2010年の8月
私が社長になるタイミングに合わせて
松華堂菓子店というのをつくりました
今ここですね
さて 皆さんは「経営者」という言葉に
どんなイメージをお持ちでしょうか
私は正直あまり良いイメージを持っていませんでした
高級車に乗りたいと特に思わないし
偉くなりたいとも思ったことがなかった
だから何がほしいとか 何になりたいとかではなく
どんな人生を送ろうかという風に考えました
しかし同時に ５代目というところもあったりとか
家族を守る父親の立場であったりとか
いろんなことを考えてちょっと難しく思っていた時に
意識したのがこの言葉です
これは好きな建築家のミース・ファンデルローエの
"Less is More" という言葉です
人生は限られていて
時間もエネルギーも限られています
そんな中で 本当に自分のしたいことは何なのか
そして本当に価値のあるもの
本当に価値のある会社って何だろうって
考えたんですね
そうして 引き算に引き算をかさねて
結局は大金持ちになる必要はなく
自分で自分の得意なことを生かして
そして自分の信じる価値をつくって
それで人並みに食べていければ良い
と思って作ったのが
この松華堂菓子店です
この松華堂カステラというのは
とてもシンプルなお菓子です
地元で取れた新鮮な卵を
昔ながらの手仕事で仕込んで
そして最新のオーブンで焼き上げます
そうするとしっとりと焼き上がります
シンプルですが 今の良いところと昔の良いところ
その両方を大事に作っています
お菓子の種類もこのカステラときな粉サンドという
２種類だけです
種類が少ない分 一つ一つにこだわることができます
賞味期限は大手のお菓子に比べると
半分ぐらいですけども
保存料は使っていません
便利を捨てることで 美味しさを選びました
そうすると地元の方たちを中心に
少しずつ支持してくれる方たちが広がっていきました
広告も一切打たず
テレビの取材もお断りしているにもかかわらず
それはさらにインターネットなどで広がっていき
東京の有名百貨店の催事だったりとか
駅ビルの出店につながっていきます
"Less is More"
たくさんの可能性を捨てることで
本当に価値のあるものに出会えてきます
そういった価値というのは ブームなどに終わらず
きちんと残っていくものだと考えています
こういった考え方は 震災後 復興を考える上でも
大事なのではないかと思っています
震災後は 地域活性化とかふるさとの未来とか
いろんなところでたくさん語られるようになり
毎日のように復興イベントが行われています
しかしここで気をつけなければならないのは
それが何のためにやっているかということを
忘れてはいけないと思っています
傷ついた身体にカンフル剤や麻酔薬は
必要だと思いますが
そのまま依存すると
結局は身を滅ぼしてしまうと思います
復興というのは ある意味では
「平凡な日常」を取り戻していく
ということでもあると思います
だから私たちはそれまでに
派手な話題をふりまくのではなく
いかに地域を耕して新しい種を蒔けるか
そういったことを考えて
仲間たちと一緒に開催したのが
松島流灯会 海の盆です
このお祭りは 例年行われていた花火大会が
やはり震災のダメージで開催が難しい中で行われました
派手でもないし 小さなお祭りです
しかし盛大な花火の代わりに
30年前に途切れていた盆踊りを復活させました
そして700年続く松島の瑞巌寺の
祈祷行事である大施餓鬼会や
鎮魂の灯籠流しに
もう一度スポットを当てなおしました
「本当に大事なものは何か」を考えた時に
やはり松島でしかない風景と
そしてそこに住む人々の笑顔を大切に開催したのです
当初は地元でも 小さくて地味なお祭りだ
というような批判もあったのですが
今ではたくさんの地域の人が
参加してくれるようになりました
花火見学ではなく
参加してくれるようになったのです
参加してくれた人たちは それをきっかけに
地元への愛情と そして松島の魅力を
再認識していきます
そういった想いが 各自それぞれ発信されていきます
私はそれが結果的に地域ブランドのようなものに
つながっていくのではないかなと
そう考えています
１日だけの集客ではなく 10年後 100年後のために
種を蒔いているのです
このお祭りは 他所との競争や比較ではなく
その土地本来のアイデンティティを確立する
お祭りとして評価され
グッドデザイン賞をいただくこともできました
震災でたくさんのものが失われました
しかし同時に 本当に大事なものは何か ということを
考えさせられるきっかけでもあったと思います
そういったものは 復興が進んでも
決して忘れてはならないのではないかと考えています
さて 大好きな言葉があります
"BIGになるより GOODになろう"
偉い人の言葉ではありません
震災後 ある雑誌で
子どもたちが未来について語り合う
記事の中で見つけた言葉です
このような言葉をいろんなところで使っていると
大先輩の経営者の人たちには
「お前はスケールが小さいな」とか
「草食男子だな」とか
そんな風によくバカにされます
ただ 誤解してほしくないのは
大きくなれないから負け惜しみを言っている訳ではなく
それを求めていないのです
遥か昔 強くて大きい恐竜は絶滅し
小さくても環境に適応していったものたちは生き残り
そして 進化し続けています
バブルの崩壊とか震災とか
いろんな時代の流れの中で
人々の価値も大きく変わっていると思います
価値観の変化というものは 大きく言うと
量的価値から質的価値に変わってきています
そして人々の欲求の変化
これはやはり 拡大の時代には
人に羨ましがられたいとか
人に尊敬されたいとか
そういった欲求がベースにあって
皆さん仕事や経営をしてきたのかと思います
ただしこれも 今はだんだんと
自分の能力を生かしたいとか
自分らしく生きたいと
そんな風に変わってきているのではないでしょうか
そう考えると 先進国では
よく好景気が終わると不況だという話になりますが
もしかすると そうではなくて
単純に成金から成熟に
向かっているだけなのではないかなと思います
そうであるとするならば
経営の手法もそれに合わせていくべきかなと
人口が増えて みんなが同じ方向を向いていた時は
強さや早さなどを競うような
そういった狩猟型の経営で良かったのかと思いますが
人口が減り そして人々の欲求が
多様化していくとするならば
それに合わせて多様な種を蒔いて
新しい価値を創造していくような
そんな経営方法が必要になってくるのだと思います
そういった経営方法のポイントは３つあると思います
一人の人が大きいものを育てて
そこに依存するのもいいのですが
できるだけたくさんの人が
それぞれ好きなことをやり始めればいいなと思います
それを適材適所で 適正規模で
これ すごく当たり前なことを言っているように
思えるかもしれませんが
意外と難しいものです
特にこの３番目の「適正規模」というのは
経営者の方はわかるかもしれないですけども
結構難しいんですね
でもこういった考え方 東北の人が得意そうな
考え方じゃないかなと思っています
わかりやすい例が 軒並みファーストフードの
チェーン店などが苦戦している中で
地方にたくさんの小さな個人経営のカフェが
生まれています
インターネットのおかげもあって
小さくても特色があってグッドであれば
経営が成り立つようになってきたんですね
では特色はどうやって出していったらいいんだろう
そこにはやはり その地域の文化であったり
そのオーナーの個性であったりということだと思います
そのためには 他との比較ではなく
自分の物差しで物事を考え判断する
こういったことが必要です
実はこれが東北の人が一番苦手なことかと思います
だけどもそれができれば
大変かもしれないけど それぞれがワクワクして
楽しい生活になっていくと思います
そして他との比較をやめることによって
コンプレックスから解放されて
他の人の意見を聞き入れたりだとか
多様な価値観を認め合えるような
そんな考え方に広がっていくのではないでしょうか
一つ一つは小さくても
そういった考え方が広がっていけば
私は本当にワクワクする未来で
持続可能で平和な社会になっていくだろうと思います
一つ一つは小さくても
色とりどりの多様な価値観が
存在できるような
成熟した社会
改めて言います
私は経営者です
経営者の目的というのが 必ずしも
限界のない富の膨張ではなくて
自分の得意なこと 自分の好きなことで
人を喜ばせて
「Bigになるより Goodになろう」
こういったことを軸にやっていくと
それほどRichにはなれないけどHappyになれます
そういったものが一つ一つ
小さいHappyがつながっていくと
WIN x WINからHAPPY x HAPPYの関係
すごく能天気な言葉なんですけれも
意外とこういったことが経営者の成熟であり
そして経営者の進化ではないかと
そんな風に思います
以上です ありがとうございました